yeah welcome to this video playing ozr
from the US so an English opening yeah
how'd you go now yeah there are many
many ways to to play this d 596 check
out this one
King everyone yeah there are moves under
the Sun yeah just Bishop t to us it's
normal I don't know why you would why
you would play em without castling here
it's not like that that bishop is so
terribly misplaced came just develop him
Kim I guess it's best to open up the
position quickly he's playing some some
weird moves came so I can't even play c5
and deform or h6 but on age 60 probably
will ignore the threat to the bishop
pizza probably just having some fun with
the way it moves you cannot really think
that this is this is good
okay so i have six wins i win two piece
time I don't I don't know why I
shouldn't really
yeah it's just a piece for for nothing
yeah I hope that I'll get some attack
out of this I have an extra piece quite
often the best way is just to start a
direct attack using your piece not
trying to I don't know trade down to an
end game but just attack with the extra
piece and I think this is working and
nicely don't see a movie em just opening
up the fr yeah just wait for a second is
something better even then 93 yeah
Queenie 5 threatening Queen g3 is not
not bad check yeah this is winning check
even more material white resigned yeah
weird game yeah sometimes I think
they're just drunk it happens I mean
I've played my share of games but mostly
in bullet while having a couple a couple
of beers too many yeah king of one is
just weird Bishop detour so check this
is the normal way to play that but um
yeah a position then it's probably
slightly better for white but pretty
solid for black yakking everyone is not
to not really great and okay this age 4
and so on yeah it needs to be punished
and I think I did a good job doing that
thanks for watching